[Musique]
tellement crevin
joutes du genre de rencontre la
gbl est énorme à m tom hardy arrête de
te raconter des conneries
cet homme non mais c'est vrai un chai la
raclée de punaises me a été une meule
une grosse malle ans ça va être super
je vais être un peu plus sérieuse
finalement la voix c'est quoi la voix
c'est un instrument avant que vous ne
pourrez pas acheter ni sur internet ni
dans une boutique comme un saxophone ou
un piano la voix c'est vous c'est tout
votre coeur car c'est tout votre mental
et c'est tout votre vécu si je reviens
précisemment sur l'instrument
l'instrument c'est donc la soufflerie
dans les poumons en en deux c'est le
vibrateur ici le larynx dans lequel il
ya deux cordes vocales qui vont vibrer
au passage de l'air et au dessus ce
qu'on appelle le masque ce sont les
résonateurs et on va faire glissé toutes
ces choses qui vibre dans l'arrière de
la gorge on va venir les les envoyer
dans le masque pour trouver de la
couleur du timbre et du volume de voix
et tout ça nous l'aborderons ensemble
plus précisément une prochaine fois
voilà ça fait
ça fait deux heures que je travaille sur
le télescope et suite ou congelés
- 70 degrés
[Musique]